We plan to put a lot of other JANET core equipment so as you can imagine
JANET supports research and education. A lot of students are using the network, not only for their studies
but, they live in halls of residence so
we move a lot of Netflix traffic around the network
so we'll be putting some netflix caches that help to manage that traffic more efficiently on the network.
[Are there any other services like Netflix that you'll be doing that for? Like Google or anything like that?]
We have direct pairings with Google and
Amazon to manage their traffic directly on the network.
[So if anyone's watching Amazon Prime video it's the same sort of thing]
it is yes, that'll go across JANET directly into the Amazon network
[So how much spare capacity is there here?]
We've got Terabits essentially of spare capacity
in the current system.
This is where the JANET network enters the datacenter
The datacenter is actually on the core of the JANET network so we have diverse fibre, going out to two of our...
core points of presence one in East London, in Docklands, and one in West London
and that's how it connects to the JANET
network so we have our optical equipment
lighting that fiber. Which is Cienna optical equipment so at the moment we've got two 200 gig
wavelengths and we're about to add a second set of a hundred Gig wavelengths as well
and then we have the Juniper routing equipment
[If we were to look in the hole, where the cables come from all the universities what would we see?]
Well it's not that exciting its basically a pair of fibers in one side of the building and
then another pair of fibers coming to
the other side of the building and as I
say those fibers go to a location in
East London and then a location in West London.
[and then they go into here and get distributed amongst all your...]
That's right, they go into the optical equipment and then into the IP switching equipment
and we either present one Gig connections or 10 Gig connections to each of the customers.
The two fibers come in. They first of all come in
to the the optical equipment and that
does the de-multiplexing out of the light
signal and then that gets put into the
switching and routing equipment to which
each of the customers in the datacenter
connect so we have; out of the routing
equipment individual pairs of fiber that go into either data hall one or data hall two.
It's fibre coming out of the
equipment and that goes to the the in-datacenter patching
Infrastructure. So the Ciena equipment there, that, on a single fiber
is essentially capable of carrying
8.8 Terabits of information. At the moment as
we're growing into the datacenter we've got two hundred Gigabits, soon to move up to four hundred Gigabits.
This is the core equipment that powers the JANET network
so we have a national core that extends from Exeter in the south-west to Edinburgh &
Glasgow in Scotland we have about six
and a half thousand kilometers of fiber
that connects all that core equipment - and that core connects to 17 regional
distribution networks that then connects to the universities and colleges and the public
research institutions
so the signals come in to the optical
equipment, the Ciena equipment and then get
patched into the Juniper IP
switching and routing equipment in this
rack here. This is taking the signal out of the optical equipment converting that light
into the Internet protocol signal and then
customers connect out on individual ports
signals come out of that Juniper IP equipment. Come in via the fiber patching, into
this patching rack and then that'll go off into the wiring infrastructure on this yellow overhead trunking. So we
connect two ways out into the data hall so it's fully resilient so it'll come out into two
of the overhead raceways, and then be diversely
routed - take different routes
into the data hall that it's going into.
So if one of these overhead raceways were to be damaged, the other raceway would carry the signal.
[Have you had anything like that happen yet?] No we haven't, no not in the data centre. [and how long's this been in force, this system?]
It's nearly a year now it's been up and running. [and have you seen major differences using this system than before, how you had it before?]
Well this is our first data centre on the network so this is the first time we've done this!
reader rather than just a traditional
fingerprint reader actually searching
for signs of life so as to make sure
that you have enough in your car from
someone who gets to use the power and
when that is a very important component
in the great which is what we call them
even wear